Welcome back everyone this will be my full book
of boba fett episode 7 finale video there were
a whole bunch of easter eggs and things setting up
the mandalorian season three so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything i will be doing
videos for the mandalorian season three and for
the obi-wan kenobi episodes that we're going to be
getting in may may the 4th be with you and a whole
bunch of obi-wan kenobi versus darth vader careful
for spoilers for the episode if you haven't seen
it yet i'll just start at the beginning and we'll
go through scene by scene talking about easter
eggs wtf moments as we go along starting with
the episode title in the name of honor it's mainly
meant to be a reference to boba fett's honor and
how his character has changed over time how he's
changed since he's been with cad bane because cad
bane keeps throwing that in his face telling him
that he's a cold-blooded killer but we've seen how
boba fett has changed since he was rescued by the
tusken raiders and was taken into their tribe how
he's trying to take care of the people of tatooine
and do right by them in the title of honor is also
meant to be a reference to the mandalorian din
jarrin's honor because maya's mandalorian creed
he's going to honor the promise that he made to
help boba fett but the actual opening scene is
a boba fett fenix shand and mando inspecting the
ruins of madame garza flips bar after the bombing
press f to pay respects for her r.i.p i guess
she's confirmed dead now because she didn't
come back for those of you asking about max
rebo though there were all these memes after
last week's episode because max rebo was not in
the cantina playing with the band when it was
blown up confirming that he did survive but now
everybody's like wait a minute what did he know
obviously that's not true john favreau and dave
filoni just didn't want to kill off max rebo so
they just conveniently made it so that he wasn't
there when this happened they make a bunch of
references to cobb vanth and the other townspeople
from mos pelgo who they believe are coming to help
them which they do by the end of the episode but
it takes them a while to find out what actually
happened between cobb vanth and cad bane boba fett
does agree to stop all spice trade in and around
the mos pelgo area of tatooine and even though
fenix shan seems really upset by this like we're
going to lose a bunch of money they're not going
to lose that much money the only difference now is
they just have to go around mos pelgo they just
can't go through it they make a bunch of cobb
vanth references throughout the episode but if it
wasn't clear obviously who survived that's what
the whole post credit scene was about i'll talk
more about that when we get to that part of the
episode he's in the bacta tank thundercat's gonna
upgrade him with some cybernetics he'll be fine
then right after talking about cobb vanth right
on cue cad bane walks into town stranger walks
into town they pay off the joke about the
javas yoinking parts off everything in sight
they finally reveal the ithorian mayor moch
chaise played by robert rodriguez director
of a lot of the episodes in the series has been
holed up with this same pike syndicate captain
played by phil lamar this whole time if it wasn't
clear he was meant to be the same pike that boba
fett tried to bargain with in the flashbacks he's
just been the pike who's been in charge of their
operation on tatooine the whole time answering
to the syndicate leaders back on their homeworld
obadiah if you didn't watch the clone wars
episodes that planet was featured during those
episodes is up here in this part of the outer rim
along the kessel run they do reference the pike's
home planet a couple times later in the episode
the captain reveals that they're the ones who
orchestrated the killings of boba fett's tusken
raider tribe because they didn't want to have
to pay their fees there were a lot of people that
were wondering if it actually would have been cad
bane like there was going to be some twist behind
who really killed the tusken raiders and there was
a twist but it was the pikes that killed them and
they just made it look like the red nickto speeder
bike gang they have a couple scenes with the pike
captain and the mayor here just to foreshadow
fenik shan showing up to kill them later revenge
style that even though it's not luke skywalker
himself his x-wing returns to his home planet
tatooine again for the first time that we know
of since the events of return of the jedi when he
came to rescue han solo and the others from jabba
the hutt confirming all of our theories about the
choice the grogu would make during episode six
there were so many scenes with luke skywalker and
grogu and mando and ahsoka just setting up grogu
choosing mando over luke skywalker and the jedi
path and i do like the way they just kind of skip
past that part like they just show the x-wing
showing up on tatooine again and you instantly
understand the choice that grogu made they also
transitioned from this shot of luke skywalker's
x-wing to another anakin skywalker easter egg
for his father who also grew up on tatooine
with the petroids from phantom menace waking
up from stasis when the proximity alerts go off
i also think that pelle motto's hangar bay here in
the mos eisley space port is meant to be the same
hanger bay that han solo parked the millennium
falcon in during a new hope all of the droids
that she's had with her so far this season show
up again the bd1 droid the calcustas had in jedi
fallen order it's not the exact same droid that
calcustas had it's just the same type of droid the
new type of gonk droid the r5 droid the treadwell
droid a lot of these droids not all of them but a
lot of them are from the beginning of a new hope
they try to reuse as many old props and droids as
possible in star wars productions so if you feel
like an object or a weapon or even a small detail
in the background of any scene in any star wars
episode or movie is an easter egg for something
it probably is love the way they reveal grosgu
crawling out of the x-wing cockpit is it they're
joking that he piloted it here himself he
is smart enough to do that but the cockpit
controls are just not set up for someone his size
so it would be almost impossible practically for
him to do it like he just couldn't reach all the
buttons even though he does love to push buttons
that's why r2d2 gets all pissy with pele motto
because he's basically saying no i'm the one
that piloted the x-wing i think it's better they
did it this way than bringing back luke skywalker
again just to come drop him off on tatooine it's
always cool to see their luke skywalker scenes
see how they've evolved their deep fake technology
but i feel like less is more when it comes to luke
skywalker stuff notice though very carefully
if you look in the cockpit grogu does not have
yoda's lightsaber and later in the episode he
also doesn't have it anywhere on him everyone
was wondering if we knew that he was going to
choose the mandalorian armor would luke still
let him have yoda's lightsaber or would grogu try
to yoink it or would it just stay with luke so for
now i'm just assuming that it's staying with luke
skywalker at the jedi temple groku could always go
back and get it later in the timeline before the
destruction of the temple personally i think it'd
be more impactful if eventually at some point in
the future he constructs his own lightsaber but
like right now for instance his tiny little hands
aren't even big enough to wrap around the hilt of
yoda's little lightsaber and it's already a very
small lightsaber the only way grogu will wield a
lightsaber short term like in the next couple of
seasons of the mandalorian or wherever else he
shows up is if he throws the darksaber or someone
else's lightsaber using the force which would
actually be really cool pelimado kinda does grosgu
dirty here saying that he's got a terrible name
and there's no way she's calling him that i think
that's dave filoni and jon favreau just making
jokes about everyone in real life who wanted
to keep calling him baby yoda even after they
revealed his true name like i'm not going to call
him grogu i'm still going to call him baby yoda
maybe because he's part of yoda's species but
he's also taken the mandalorian armor become a
mandalorian we should call him the yoda lorian
love the way the tiny mandalorian armor looks
on him too best guard chainmail tailor made
to fit his tiny little body for those of you
asking obviously if he outgrows it while amando is
still alive because he'll grow very slowly mando
would just replace it with a larger version the
scene of him eating the worms slurping them down
really funny it just meant to be a callback to
that scene from the mandalorian season 2 when he
was eating the seafood with mando before they met
bo katan and the night owls i know you're hungry
it's almost like tradition now that in every
single episode that features grogu there has to
either be a scene of him trying to eat something
or make a reference to being hungry and wanting
more food we get our first boba fett vs cad
bane gunslinger rematch standoff cad bane uses
the same insult that boba fett did earlier in the
series kind of implying that boba fett learned the
insult from him originally when he was training
under him as a bounty hunter all of that isn't
the quaker calling the stiffling slimy if that's
not the quacker calling the stiffling slimy as i
explained in my previous episode videos there's
a lot of untold history between the two of them
that dave filoni had established during the clone
wars episodes when boba fett was still very young
there was a batch of lost clone wars episodes that
were unfinished and he never brought back during
the clone wars season seven in part of those
episodes we're going to cover the story of boba
fett training with cad bane going on adventures
in how their relationship plays out in that part
of the timeline they make a lot of references
to that period in their life during the episode
that's why cad bane makes so many references to
teaching boba fett more lessons like this will
be my final lesson to you because boba fett
learned to be a bounty hunter from cad bane
originally those lost clone wars episodes with the
two of them together were going to end with them
having a big gunslinger standoff where boba fett
gets cad bane but he almost kills boba fett with
a head shot he's saved by his mandalorian armor
and that's how his helmet got the dent in it and
that's why in episode 6 cad bane told kavvanth
that he should have kept the armor he also tells
boba fett the same thing in this episode you
should have let him keep the armor whereas the
early boba fett episodes were going for more of
a godfather in space vibe with him taking over
jabba's criminal empire since mando showed up the
whole tone of the show has shifted back to classic
space western cad bane for instance very much
inspired by the lee van cleef character from the
good the bad and the ugly and that's kind of the
way they use him in the series mando is the good
cad bane is the bad and boba fett is the ugly
they confirm my theory that some of boba fett's
factions in his alliance jabba's former kapos
betray them to the pike syndicate you could
also make a red wedding game of thrones reference
the pikes send their regards the same way roose
bolton and the freys betrayed the starks at the
last minute it's the aqualish the trandocians
and the cletuians so you have to assume that after
their victory at the end of the episode boba fett
then eventually goes around and deals with all
these capos and either gets them in line or just
flat out kills them off r.i.p to the gomorian
guards they never reference their des later in
the episode like nobody ever says anything about
them after this like what happened to the guards
where'd they go did they just take off maybe we
should check on that press f to pay respects they
also set up the scene of them inside the ruins
of the cantina as things turn against them as
a parallel for the mandalorian season one finale
where they were surrounded by mafkidian's forces i
guess if we're making western references you could
make a young guns reference too to the ending of
that movie the way they bust out of the house the
whole conversation that mando and boba fett have
here about not wanting to bail on each other is
also meant to play into the theme of the episode
in the name of honor like in the name of their
own honor the mandalorian honor the mandalorian
creed boba fett's own honor his own code they will
not bail when mando says that they'll both die in
the name of honor you could also think of it as
another game of thrones reference because pedro
pascal played oberyn martell in game of thrones
season 4 and there's a big ned stark honor theme
during season 1 where cersei lannister basically
tells ned stark your honor will get you killed
here which it did she was 100 correct about that
mando says his trademark catchphrase again this
is the way the twilight major dormo reveals that
he went to a rich kid prep school on coruscant
and they use his talent for speechifying to just
stall the pikes for time when he mentions the
obadia high council that's just the group that
rules over the pike syndicate on their homeworld
boba fett amanda used their jet packs again
finally to surprise them with an aerial assault
it's also meant to be a callback to mando and cobb
vanth both using the exact same jet packs because
it was still boba fett's armor to attack the crate
dragon during the mandalorian season 2 except this
time it's two people who are well versed in the
art of the rising phoenix as the armorer calls
their jetpacks they finally let them use a lot of
their really cool mandalorian weapons boba fett
uses his knee rockets a bunch of times mando uses
his whistling birds again too them soaking both
of them in blaster fire with their best gar armor
is also meant to be a callback to mando using his
to serve as a human shield for bacta tank and the
night owls during season two their armor can soak
a ton of energy damage like that it still hurts
them a lot but the armor itself will not crack
then if you want to make another game of thrones
reference you could also say the large land
speeder with the mos pelgo people riding in to
help them is kind of like the knights of the vale
coming in to save jon snow in the others during
the battle of the bastards during season six
you probably recognize that land speeder that
they ride in on it's the same one that's inside
owen and berular's home during a new hope it's
called a v35 courier it was also featured in mos
pelgo during the mandalorian season 2. they bring
back that same weak way bartender played by w earl
brown from justified and deadwood same shows that
timothy olyphant came from and he references cad
bane and cobb vanth's standoff all these different
references just meant to set up that post-credit
scene where they reveal him inside the bacta tank
healing and getting ready to get his cybernetic
enhancements they give black krssantan a bunch
of badass takedowns he also winds up soaking
almost as much blaster fire as mando and boba
fett do without the best car armor to help him
he's just that tough like wookies are just that
tough then this big second wave of giant droids
that look like droid dakotas are actually
scorpenec annihilator droids they're still
from the star wars prequels just like the droid
because they're kind of like modified upgraded
droid because they're a super deep cut prequels
easter egg because the scorpion egg droids were
actually the original concept art version of what
would eventually become the droidkas in the actual
prequel movies they do this kind of thing in star
wars all the time where they'll bring back some
unused concept art as something slightly different
in like a future project they did the same thing
with the tank from the mandalorian season 2 like
the tank was an unused concept design from empire
strikes back in the original trilogy that george
lucas later brought back during the prequels is
a slightly larger version the tank was originally
supposed to show up during empire strikes back and
even though they didn't use it in empire strikes
back i think that they actually did sell it as a
toy that you could buy back in the day boba fett
uses his rocket launcher again finally always love
when he uses the rocket launcher mando tries to
use his flamethrower in the darksaber against
their shields but it's all meant to set up the
really badass takedowns with the baby rancor
and with grogu later in the episode where they
all team up and work together to take them down
that's also why they show you black kyrsantan
being able to push one of his hands through
one of their shields just to foreshadow the baby
rancor being powerful enough to do that with his
arms right on cue pelimado shows up with the pit
droids for some reason and grogu in tow her lying
about the force working in mysterious ways is just
meant to obviously directly set up grogu using
the force to disable their rickshaw cart droid so
that he can use the force to destroy the scorpene
egg droids with their help you have to remember
that grogu even though he seems like a child is
over 50 years old so he's actually really smart
he just seems like a tiny little baby love the
boba fett reveal entering on the rancor's back
they finally pay off him learning to ride it
and it wrecks the hell out of the scorpionectoids
both of them they weakened the shields just enough
for mando to get in some hits with the darksaber
and grogu rolling up like a boss to force lift it
that's also meant to be a callback to him saving
mando from the mudhorn during the mandalorian
season one by lifting it into the air the joke
about him accidentally pulling the droid's bolt
to him so fast that it knocks him on his ass
is just to show you that he still has a lot of
force training left to do like he's very powerful
in the force but he's not invincible they even
give the rancor a legit finishing move fatality
like give us mortal kombat but make it star wars
wins fatality the way he destroys the second one
they also want to show you just how formidable the
rancor can be when trained properly and remember
this is still just a baby rancor it's meant to
be a parallel for grogu like super powerful
creature that will someday be way more powerful
because they make a king kong reference later you
could make some godzilla vs kong references with
their fight here with the rancor ripping apart
the same way that kong rips apart mechagodzilla
when the raincore starts throwing all the pike
syndicate people around and eating them they give
a couple of wilhelm screams it'd be weird if they
did star wars without some wilhelm screams in it
and it would have been weird for them to make all
those raincore pit references earlier in the show
and then not have a rancor eat someone and then
they finally pay off the big boba fett versus
cad bane rematch they make even more references
to those lost clone wars episodes with the two
of them flying around together having adventures
as bounty hunters and it's just meant to show you
how he's evolved over time how now he is a much
more honorable person the way their fight actually
goes down cad bane being a faster draw than him is
canon that's why boba fett admits that he's faster
but his mandalorian armor protects him that's more
references to their last gunslinger standoff where
cad bane gave him the dent in his helmet with the
headshot they referenced his father jango fett
again and him beating him with his tusken raider
gaffe stick is also meant to be symbolic because
he's not just looking out for himself anymore
he's being less selfish he learned the skills
with the tuskens that he needed to beat cad bane
like if he'd been the same version of boba fett
that he was during the original trilogy they're
implying the cat bane would have killed him
it's only because of the lessons that he learned
with the tuskins recently that he won the fight
so r.i.p cadbane pressed f in the chat to pay
respects he was a badass bounty hunter and a
really cool character so it sucks that they did
kill him off and they showed you his death in the
body after here to confirm the kill so there's
no confusion it's like darth maul being killed
by obi-wan during star wars rebels like you're
meant to see the body nope he's definitely dead
this time the rancor climbing the tower is meant
to be a classic king kong reference if you look at
the concept art over the end credits it's a more
literal king kong reference because he's holding
the woman as he's climbing the tower but they
didn't do that in the final version of the episode
probably just to save a little bit of money
the land speeder that he picked up and tried
to eat then threw at all the people is just a
blue version of luke skywalker's land speeder
mando gives grogu the ball of joint from the razor
crest that he played with during season 1 and
season 2 he saved it back during season 2 before
moff gideon destroyed the razor crest that's why
he still hasn't the way the rancor tries to
eat mando though here is kind of funny it's
like a little kid putting an action figure in his
mouth trying to eat it and they pay off another
size matters not yoda seen again when grogu calms
down the rancor using the force size mattress matt
look at me just mean by my size do you and
where you should not which just like the mud
horn scene during season one tires him out just
enough that he plops down right next to him and
they both have a really solid nap in the middle of
the street here then they pass by the stormtrooper
helmets on the pikes in mos eisley to foreshadow
the death of the pikes heads on pikes and dead
pikes i see what you did there star wars fennek
shand executes the rest of the pike's syndicate
leadership along with the mayor now former mayor
r.i.p also getting justice for the tusken raiders
then i've been a big fan of the book of boba fett
theme music but when they're walking through mos
espa as they're all rebuilding they play this
cool western version of the regular boba fett
theme music the reference to the bacta tank being
used is obviously meant to be a reference to
the post-credits scene with cobb vanth healing
himself the scene with a special fruit here is
meant to be another godfather movie's reference
with the oranges and the fruit in the street
like boba fett is now the godfather of tatooine
also that fruit was featured during star wars
rebels and during the bad batch episodes then
when everyone's reuniting at the end they bring
back the rat catcher droid too like the rat
catcher droid is now fully a member of the crew
and they do this cool mashup version of the boba
fett theme music and then the mandalorian theme
music as they transition to the shot of mando
and grogu leaving tatooine in the new naboo
n1 starfighter paying off the references about
the tiny grogu sized pod that used to be used
by the r2 units grogu tapping the glass over and
over again to get him to punch the boosters is
another callback to the mandalorian season 1 when
he kept reaching to push the button over and over
and the whole idea here is that the mandalorian
season 3 episode 1 will pick up with the next
adventure that they're currently on their way
to and we'll get those episodes by the end of
this year i'll do a larger mandalorian season
3 video before i do my next peacemaker video
but the post-credits scene is cobb vanth
recovering in the bacta tank back at jabba's
palace thundercat's character preparing to modify
him with cybernetic parts just like fenix shand
just to confirm that he is alive he will
come back in some future star wars project
if you spotted any of their big easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments and i will
do a couple other bonus videos this weekend for
everything because there's still a lot of stuff
that we have to talk about maybe if we're lucky
we'll get some super bowl trailer footage for
the obi-wan kenobi series but no promises there
everyone click here for my grogu luke skywalker
video and click here for that brand new marvel
x-men teaser video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and this is the way!